But the last oncology appointment, they were concerned about possible infection.
So they prescribed it antibiotic to take for five days.
I protested because I have a history of not tolerating antibiotics.
But they said, five days would not be a problem.
Well, it was and my God has been telling me, is there something I could do to improve that?
So when you take antibiotics, it damages your gut microbiota.
And antibiotics will damage the cells of the gut lighting, the epithelial cells that might the gut.
And it just throws off your whole flora and throws off your everything.
I'm not saying that you shouldn't take antibiotics at different times.
But some people are more susceptible to issues with antibiotics, too.
Personally, I can take antibiotics and have no trouble.
But honestly, I think I've taken antibiotics, you know, maybe, maybe, you know,
half a dozen times in my life.
It's, you know, it, it, it, it's um, it partly has to do with the healthy your gut before you start to take it antibiotics.
What to do to improve that though?
You have to work on healing the gut.
I would say start on some, so I think I made a blog post not specifically antibiotics.
But let me go to that because I think I actually linked it to our home page of the member site.
So on the member site home page, I think I have a link to, I don't know, I don't know, I don't know.
So, okay, so, okay.
So, yes, I think it's the top.
Well, it ties into H.
Because, because, you know, you think what is H by Laura have to do it, we take the antibiotics, some damage that I got.
Because that's how it starts.
So damage got, so H by Laura is killed by antibiotics, but it's not going to kill everything.
So anything that damages your gut increases the risk of H by Laura starting.
So, um, look at this post on it's called H chemical factor.
Pylori intramation and care.
And that goes through the different steps to do to work on healing your gut.
So, it's the post that looks like that.
So, look at this post and it goes through the steps stage one, look at dietary allergens.
Well, that's not your issue.
Make sure you're taking digestive enzymes with HCl in it.
Because you need to support your stomach's ability to break down the food.
And many, many times that is the reason why people don't tolerate antibiotics is because they have a decrease HCl in their stomach.
So, look at that part.
Step two is looking at supporting your gut.
I would not take necessarily take pair of clear to begin with.
See if I have more information on that.
Um, I will, if I, I will find the post.
I'll put it up on the member site that has more information on healing your gut.
And what to take for that.
And give me tell tomorrow when I'll do that.